- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance est
ouverte.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par madame la
vice-présidente Valérie Rabault.
- Valérie Rabault: La baguette
vient d'être reconnue à l'Unesco.
C'est dans son propre pays, la
France, qu'elle est en danger
aujourd'hui.
Il y a une explosion des coûts de
l'électricité dans les
boulangeries tout simplement parce
que pour faire cuire du pain, il
faut un four qui ait une puissance
supérieure que celle qui est
réglementée dans les tarifs.
Les boulangers ont deux solutions.
Soit faire tendre le prix de la
baguette vers 2 euros, soit mettre
la clé sous la porte.
Nous vous le demandons
solennellement, nous voulons un
bouclier tarifaire avec un tarif
réglementé pour les boulangeries.
Je souhaite votre réponse sur ce
point.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Bruno Le Maire,
ministre de l'Economie, des
Finances et de la Souveraineté
industrielle et numérique.
- Bruno Le Maire: Madame la
députée Rabault, je veux vous
rassurer, nous ne laisserons
tomber aucun boulanger en France,
comme nous ne laisserons tomber
aucune PME ni aucune TPE face à
l'augmentation des coûts.
J'ai reçu longuement les
représentants des boulangers.
Nous essayerons de trouver des
solutions particulières pour les
boulangeries qui sont confrontées
au problème que vous avez décrit
de l'explosion des coûts de
l'électricité et des fours qui
doivent tourner pour faire cuire
le pain.
Nous avons mis en place un
guichet.
J'invite toutes les TPE qui ne
l'ont pas encore fait à venir
déposer leurs factures pour 2022
pour bénéficier des aides à
hauteur de 4000 euros.
Pour l'année 2023, nous mettrons
en place un amortisseur
d'électricité pour toutes les PME
de moins de 250 salariés.
Elles auront une réduction de
leurs factures en moyenne de 20%.
Si jamais cela ne suffit pas, nous
sommes prêts à regarder ce qui
doit être mis en place de
complémentaire pour aider un
certain nombre de professions
confrontées à des situations
particulières.
Les boulangers en font partie.
Je vous le dis avec beaucoup de
sincérité, pendant la crise du
Covid, nous n'avons laissé tomber
aucune PME en difficulté.
A l'époque, c'était l'hôtellerie
et la restauration.
Nous avons accompagné, face à
l'explosion des prix de
l'électricité, qui touche
certaines entreprises très
ciblées, ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin pour qu'ils puissent passer
cette période avec le moins de
difficultés possibles.
- Valérie Rabault: Vous allez
prendre en charge 20% seulement de
la hausse des coûts.
Je vais vous donner un exemple
très concret.
Une boulangerie payait 1500 euros
par mois de frais d'électricité.
Cette facture passe à 4500 euros.
Sur les 4500 euros, vous allez en
prendre 900 en charge.
Il lui reste 3600 euros à payer.
Cette boulangerie compte deux
travailleurs.
Ils travaillent toute la journée.
Ces 3600 euros de frais
d'électricité, ils ne peuvent pas
les absorber aujourd'hui.
Ils vont fermer début
janvier 2023.
Il y a déjà dans mon département
cinq boulangeries qui ont fermé.
Il faut que vous nous écoutiez
tout de suite.
Il faut que le tarif réglementé
soit mis en place tout de suite,
sans attendre.
Vous avez fait référence au fonds
de solidarité en disant que vous
n'aviez laissé tomber personne
lors de la crise sanitaire.
C'est vrai, mais vous avez attendu
que nous vous relancions.
Ce sera une catastrophe dans nos
communes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Sylvain
Maillard pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Sylvain Maillard: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre,
depuis quelques jours, nous
sentons une inquiétude monter chez
nos concitoyens.
Nous observons deux attitudes.
D'une part, les actions portées
par le gouvernement pour parer aux
difficultés énergétiques.
D'autre part, des expressions
alarmistes qui voudraient
entretenir la peur.
En effet, il y a quelques jours,
le gouvernement a donné
instruction aux préfets de
départements de préparer des
scénarios de délestage en cas de
tensions graves sur le réseau
d'électricité.
L'objectif de cette mesure vise à
prévenir tout risque de coupure
généralisée en janvier qui
impacterait trop fortement le
fonctionnant dans notre pays.
Nos concitoyens, nos entreprises,
nos industries effectuent depuis
plusieurs jours des efforts de
sobriété pour rationaliser nos
consommations d'énergie.
Pourtant, dès l'annonce de cette
mesure de précaution, certains
parmi ceux qui siègent dans cet
hémicycle ont propagé la peur.
Il faut le dire et le redire
autant que faire se peut, ces
informations sont fausses.
Nous savons tous que notre
politique de sobriété devrait nous
permettre de passer cet hiver sans
coupure d'électricité.
D'ailleurs, le scénario d'un
délestage au mois de décembre a
été écarté par RTE.
Pour certains groupes politiques,
la capacité à prévoir et anticiper
tout scénario serait déjà une
faute.
Notre majorité assume de tout
faire pour protéger les hôpitaux,
nos écoles et l'ensemble de nos
services publics.
Car les faits sont là.
Malgré la guerre en Ukraine qui
impacte le système énergétique de
l'ensemble de l'Europe, nous
continuerons à tenir.
Quelles mesures sont prévues pour
ce délestage?
Comment votre gouvernement va les
anticiper?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, monsieur le
député Sylvain Maillard, votre
question porte sur un sujet qui
est dans l'esprit de beaucoup de
Français.
Quel sera l'impact de la situation
énergétique dans nos vies
quotidiennes?
Cette question, les Français se la
posent lorsqu'il s'agit de leur
pouvoir d'achat et de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement.
Je peux vous assurer que le
gouvernement est mobilisé depuis
des mois.
Cette mobilisation se conduit avec
ordre, méthode et dans
l'anticipation.
Se mobiliser, c'est d'abord nous
appuyer sur EDF.
J'ai eu le nouveau président de
cette entreprise depuis sa prise
de fonction.
Je peux vous garantir qu'il
partage la détermination du
gouvernement pour assurer une
production d'électricité maximale
de notre opérateur national, en
particulier grâce au redémarrage
de réacteurs nucléaires.
Partout où c'est possible, dans
des conditions de sécurité
optimale, les calendriers sont
accélérés.
Les mois de décembre et de
janvier verront le redémarrage de
nombreuses tranches nucléaires.
J'ai confiance dans cette
entreprise, dans ses agents, qui
n'ont jamais manqué à notre pays.
Se mobiliser, c'est aussi
travailler pour identifier tous
les gisements de production et
d'économie possibles dans une
période où la tension sera
maximale sur notre réseau.
C'est partager également avec nos
concitoyens l'impératif de
sobriété, comme le président de la
République l'a fait dès l'été
dernier.
Les Français l'ont parfaitement
bien compris.
La consommation a baissé de 7% à
météo identique.
Se mobiliser, c'est aussi la
solidarité européenne.
Nous avons aligné notre production
avec nos voisins européens.
Se mobiliser, c'est se donner les
moyens de réagir en cas de tension
accrue, par exemple si nous
faisons face à un épisode de
températures extrêmement
rigoureuses.
Nous avons conçu un outil qui
permet d'anticiper la situation
dans les trois jours à venir.
C'est un outil de mobilisation
individuelle et collective.
Ce sont bien des gestes simples
qui seront les plus efficaces pour
nous prémunir d'une situation
critique.
Et puis, anticiper, c'est examiner
tous les scénarios, fussent-ils
inédits, improbables.
Bien évidemment, les préfets, en
lien avec les collectivités et les
associations, étudient la manière
de protéger les Français,
notamment les plus vulnérables.
Contrairement à ce que des propos
maladroits ont pu laisser penser,
nos hôpitaux seront toujours
alimentés en électricité.
Les personnes malades à domicile
seront toujours prises en charge.
Notre engagement de tous les
instants, c'est de mobiliser
chacun pour assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement en
électricité.
Notre responsabilité, c'est de
planifier tous les scénarios sans
agiter de fausses peurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, madame la Première
ministre.
Je vous demande un peu de calme,
mes chers collègues.
Je donne la parole à monsieur
Hendrik Davi pour le groupe La
France Insoumise.
- Hendrik Davi: Les salariés de
GRDF sont en grève depuis un mois
et occupent le site de Marseille.
En 2000, quand je suis arrivé, on
revenait du monde entier pour
apprendre le savoir-faire d'EDF.
Aujourd'hui, ils préparent des
coupures de courant dans nos
écoles.
C'est une honte.
Ce sont les mots des salariés de
cette entreprise.
Ils réclament une hausse des
salaires de 4,6%.
Cela coûterait à peine 18 millions
d'euros.
Nous n'en serions pas là si vous
aviez lancé des négociations
partout en France pour indexer les
salaires sur l'inflation, comme
nous le proposions.
Vous avez choisi la répression,
aussi.
Une enquête est ouverte après le
suicide d'un salarié.
Cette situation sociale dit
beaucoup de choses de la crise
énergétique que nous traversons.
D'abord, le mépris des salariés et
la casse méthodique du service
public.
Ensuite, un manque cruel des
politiques pour rénover les
bâtiments.
Vous n'avez rien anticipé.
Des délestages sont
prévus, notamment dans les zones
rurales menaçant de désorganiser
le pays.
Les Français sont inquiets pour le
transport et les écoles.
Comment gérer la crise?
En planifiant ces délestage sur
les activités qui ne sont pas
indispensables comme la publicité
ou encore la pollution lumineuse.
Il faut préserver le chauffage de
particuliers, les transports et
les écoles.
Qu'attendez-vous pour donner
satisfaction aux salariés de ces
entreprises?
Allez-vous planifier les
délestages, préservant les plus
démunis?
Quand allez-vous recréer un
service public et intégrer de
l'énergie dont notre pays a tant
besoin pour mener à bien la
transition énergétique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Agnès Pannier-Runacher,
ministre de la Transition
énergétique.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Monsieur
le député Davi, votre question me
permet de saluer l'ensemble de la
filière énergétique et les
salariés qui sont aujourd'hui au
travail chez EDF, chez GRDF, chez
Enedis pour nous préparer dans les
meilleures conditions le passage
de l'hiver.
La négociation sociale a été
active puisque la branche a
négocié dans un temps record un
accord majoritaire.
Il a été signé par les quatre
confédérations syndicales.
Par ailleurs, l'accord...
Il y a un accord majoritaire
aujourd'hui.
Les négociations se poursuivent.
Elles ont été entamées fin
novembre.
Je veux saluer l'esprit de
responsabilité des organisations
syndicales qui se sont mobilisées
pour faire en sorte que ces
négociations aboutissent avant
terme.
Vous évoquez le sujet de notre
préparation pour l'hiver.
Vous évoquez la sobriété.
Je veux dire ici que c'est ce
gouvernement qui, sous l'égide de
la Première ministre et du
président de la République, a mis
en place un plan de sobriété qui
mobilise les grandes entreprises,
les grandes administrations, les
collectivités locales, de manière
à ce qu'elles baissent de 10% leur
consommation d'énergie dans les
deux ans qui viennent.
Ce plan porte ses fruits.
Nous constatons une baisse de 7%.
7% corrigés selon les normales
saisonnières.
Nous allons continuer à mobiliser
pour faire en sorte que ce plan
délivre sa baisse d'énergie de
manière à nous mettre du côté de
la sécurité.
- Hendrik Davi: Je doute que vous
convainquiez les salariés en grève
à Marseille.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Maxime Minot pour le
groupe Les Républicains.
- Maxime Minot: Ce boulanger au
bord des larmes a reçu comme tous
les commerçants et artisans de
notre pays le courrier de trop de
la part d'EDF.
Ce courrier annonçait une hausse
des prix de 322%.
322%!
Sur une facture annuelle, certains
passeront de 16.000 euros à 40.000
euros pour l'année 2023.
Que répondre à ces femmes et ces
hommes qui se battent au quotidien
pour survivre?
Ils ont déjà tant souffert pendant
la crise sanitaire.
Ils ont investi toutes leurs
économies dans leur passion.
Au-delà de cette terrible réalité,
c'est l'avenir du commerce et de
l'artisanat en France qui est en
jeu.
Votre gouvernement s'est saisi
bien trop tard de ce problème.
Les dispositifs se succèdent, mais
sont souvent inefficaces et font
beaucoup d'oubliés.
De nombreux artisans depuis
plusieurs semaines vous lancent un
appel au secours.
Ces personnes se sont toujours
inquiétées de leur tâche avec
rigueur, acharnement et
patriotisme.
Cette crise nous permet de vous
rappeler que oui, nos artisans
contribuent à l'aura de notre
pays.
Ils sont les derniers
représentants d'un savoir-faire
dans notre territoire.
Comment accompagner ces
professionnels dans leur quotidien
de façon pérenne sans en laisser
sur le bord du chemin?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire, ministre de l'Economie et
des Finances.
- Bruno Le Maire: La difficulté
des boulangers ne vous autorise
pas à dire n'importe quoi sur
l'action du gouvernement, qui,
depuis plusieurs semaines, discute
avec les boulangers, avec les
artisans pour trouver avec eux des
solutions.
Nos amis boulangers, avec lesquels
nous sommes en contact régulier
depuis plusieurs semaines, sont
les premiers à reconnaître que la
solution d'une extension d'une
taxe n'est pas applicable.
Elle couvrirait d'autres
entreprises qui n'en ont pas
besoin.
Elles préfèrent des aides ciblées.
C'est votre même groupe qui
viendrait nous reprocher d'avoir
une approche trop globale, qui
alimenterait l'inflation au lieu
de faire reculer l'inflation par
des mesures ciblées.
Oui, nous préférons, en accord
avec les boulangers, prendre le
temps nécessaire...
Monsieur le député, j'étais il y a
quelques jours au téléphone avec
un boulanger à
Saint-Pée-sur-Nivelle.
Je regardais ses factures.
Il y a quelques jours, j'étais à
Montceau-les-Mines.
Je suis aussi très du terrain que
vous l'êtes.
Nous leur apporterons des
solutions dans les jours qui
viennent pour qu'ils puissent
payer leurs factures et faire leur
travail!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Maxime Minot?
- Maxime Minot: Votre arrogance
cache-t-elle quelque chose?
Aujourd'hui, il ne s'agit pas de
trouver des solutions d'urgence
mais de revoir le calcul du prix
de l'électricité, notamment au
niveau européen.
Sans ça, vous pouvez craindre le
pire.
J'aimerais que vous compreniez que
ce n'est pas un cri d'alarme
individuel, mais un cri de rage de
tous les artisans de France
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Bruno Le Maire: Il n'y a aucune
agressivité de ma part.
Les modifications européennes
prendront des mois ou des années.
Nous voulons des solutions dans
les jours qui viennent, comme
vous, pour les boulangers.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Jean-Louis Bourlanges pour le
groupe Démocrate.
- Jean-Louis Bourlanges: Madame la
présidente, madame la Première
ministre, madame la ministre, mes
chers collègues, le 30 novembre
dernier, l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté à l'unanimité la résolution
visant à sanctionner l'Azerbaïdjan
et à retirer ses forces du
territoire arménien.
La France a le devoir d'exercer
toute sa solidarité à l'égard de
l'Arménie.
Elle le doit pour des raisons
historiques, compte tenu des
épreuves terribles subies par ce
peuple.
Elle le doit pour des raisons
morales.
Ce qui est en cause, c'est le
principe de nationalité.
Elle le doit aussi pour des
raisons géopolitiques vis-à-vis
d'un peuple qui est enclavé,
isolé, perdu au milieu d'un
environnement hostile.
Je voudrais vous poser deux
questions.
Premièrement, le gouvernement
partage-t-il les craintes qui sont
celles des Arméniens sur les
risques d'une relance imminente de
la guerre par l'Azerbaïdjan?
Les gesticulations diplomatiques
récentes de ce pays en particulier
et le refus de participer au
sommet européen à Bruxelles et
surtout, le blocage pendant
plusieurs heures d'un couloir
stratégique, ne sont-ils pas de
fort mauvais augure?
Comment le gouvernement français
entend y contribuer aujourd'hui
à la préservation des droits et de
l'identité culturelle des
populations arméniennes du
Haut-Karabakh?
Quels efforts déploient-ils pour
mettre en place des garanties
internationales?
Comment ne pas voir que c'est
l'identité d'un peuple et la
survie d'une nation déjà
tragiquement éprouvée par
l'histoire qui se joue
aujourd'hui?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Catherine
Colonna, ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères.
- Catherine Colonna: Monsieur le
président Bourlanges, les tensions
restent vives entre les deux pays
tant à leurs frontières que dans
le Haut-Karabakh.
Elles démontrent l'absence de
crédibilité des garanties de
sécurité que la Russie prétendait
apporter dans la région.
Dans ce contexte, la France et
l'Union Européenne restent
engagées au soutien de l'Arménie,
comme elles le sont depuis le
début.
L'action du président de la
République au sommet de Prague a
été décisive pour obtenir le
déploiement d'une mission
d'observation de l'Union
Européenne.
Elle est déployée et
opérationnelle depuis le 20
octobre.
Quelques incidents subsistent,
mais cette mission a réellement
limité les risques d'escalade en
assurant un suivi de la situation
à la frontière, comme c'était
nécessaire.
Cette présence doit se poursuivre
aussi longtemps que nécessaire.
C'est notre conviction et le
souhait des Arméniens.
De nouvelles réunions se sont
tenues ces derniers jours à
Bruxelles et à Washington,
respectivement, sur les
délimitations de la frontière et
sur le projet de traité de paix.
Ces négociations sont une chance à
saisir pour le président de la
République.
Il l'a dit au président de
l'Azerbaïdjan et au président de
l'Arménie.
Nous continuerons d'aider ces deux
pays et nous continuerons nos
affaires pour le retour de la paix
dans ces deux pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la présidente Marine Le
Pen pour le groupe Rassemblement
National.
- Marine Le Pen: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, ici,
un mort exposé sur un pont, ici un
autre à l'entrée d'un bourg...
Il y a deux semaines, un car
scolaire attaqué par une horde de
criminels.
Explosion de 153% de coups et
blessures volontaires sur des
personnes de 15 ans ou plus.
Hausse de 263,3% des vols en 2019.
Pourtant, nous sommes dans un
département français.
L'île de Mayotte est en proie à
une véritable guerre des machettes
dans l'indifférence quasi générale
des pouvoirs publics à Paris.
La situation de chaos à Mayotte ne
doit pas être considérée comme
lointaine et ultra périphérique,
mais comme un effet de loupe sur
ce qui pourrait advenir à
l'ensemble du pays.
Le passage d'un ensauvagement de
la société à une situation de
chaos hors de contrôle du
gouvernement.
Une immigration incontrôlée.
Une maternité avec en moyenne 30
naissances par jour.
77% de la population vivant sous
le seuil de pauvreté.
Une inflation des prix sans
précédent variant de 10 à 20%, en
comparaison avec la métropole.
Nous avons tant à faire pour nos
compatriotes d'outre-mer, et
particulièrement de Mayotte, pour
faire face à l'immigration
clandestine, pour la réintégration
des soignants non-vaccinés.
Qu'en est-il des annonces
tonitruantes d'Emmanuel Macron
lors de son déplacement à Mayotte
en octobre 2019?
Depuis des années, nos
compatriotes d'outre-mer
manifestent pour l'application des
services régaliens d'un Etat digne
de ce nom.
Et vous, madame la Première
ministre, l'entendez-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Madame la
présidente Le Pen, vous venez de
dresser le tableau de la situation
à Mayotte.
J'ai eu l'occasion de le dire lors
du congrès des maires, nous sommes
particulièrement attentifs à la
situation à Mayotte, que ce soit
sur le plan de la santé...
Le ministre de la Santé s'y est
rendu il y a quelques jours.
Sur le plan de la sécurité, le
ministre de l'Intérieur y est allé
il y a quelques semaines.
Il y sera de nouveau d'ici la fin
de l'année.
Je crois qu'il y a sans doute un
large consensus sur ces bancs pour
dire que la situation est très
difficile en ce qui concerne
l'immigration clandestine.
Je peux vous assurer, madame la
présidente Le Pen, que ce soit sur
les sujets de santé, de
développement économique, d'école,
d'égalité dans l'accès aux
prestations, dans l'enjeu majeur à
la sécurité, le gouvernement est
mobilisé.
Nous sommes déterminés à apporter
des réponses aux attentes de nos
concitoyens.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, madame la Première
ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Sébastien
Jumel.
- Sébastien Jumel: Madame la
Première ministre, devant les
menaces de coupure d'électricité
et l'improvisation de votre plan
de délestage, notre colère est
forte, notre colère est froide.
L'hiver vient et nous ne savons
rien sur la manière dont nous
allons traverser cette sale
période.
Ceux qui ont froid l'hiver le
savent déjà.
Vous avez montré votre incurie
devant l'explosion des prix, qui
fait mal aux industries, aux
agriculteurs, en vous révélant
totalement incapables de reprendre
la main sur le marché pour
protéger le pays.
Voilà que votre impuissance
consentie à incarner un Etat
stratège qui vous conduit à
souffler le chaud et le froid.
Vous nous invitez à ne pas
paniquer.
Vous masquez votre impréparation.
Après avoir abîmé l'hôpital, vous
nous disiez qu'il n'avait pas
d'autre choix que des privations
de liberté pendant la crise du
Covid.
Vous humiliez les Français.
Vous les menacez de couper le jus
s'ils ne sont pas exemplaires.
Nous accusons le président de la
République et son gouvernement
d'irresponsabilité énergétique.
Nous accusons le président de la
République et son gouvernement de
n'avoir rien fait dans dans les 8
dernières années pour éviter
l'effondrement de nos capacités de
production.
Nous accusons le président de la
République et son gouvernement de
se résigner à gérer la peur à
défaut de savoir gérer la crise,
en écartant délibérément le
parlement de votre stratégie de
délestage anxiogène.
Nous refusons que la vie des gens,
de nos enfants, comme celle des
plus fragiles, soit la variable
d'ajustement de votre
impréparation.
Inflation, pénurie de médicaments,
urgences qui ferment, coupures de
courant et bientôt réforme des
retraites...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie pour la parole est à
madame Agnès Pannier-Runacher,
ministre de la Transition
énergétique.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Mesdames
et messieurs les députés, monsieur
le député Jumel, la France se
prépare depuis neuf mois à faire
face à cette crise énergétique,
qui n'a rien de français puisque
c'est une crise européenne.
Lorsqu'on dépend à 40% des
livraisons de gaz de la Russie et
lorsque 20% de l'électricité
européenne est produite à base de
gaz, par construction, nous avons
une crise.
C'est ce pays qui a été l'un des
premiers à remplir ses stocks de
gaz au maximum, c'est ce pays qui
a pris des mesures au niveau
européen pour faire face à l'hiver
à venir dans les meilleures
conditions de préparation.
C'est ce pays qui vous a fait
voter un certain nombre de mesures
cet été qui nous permettent de
nous mettre à l'abri des
situations de tensions sur notre
réseau électrique dans la plupart
des situations.
Alors, monsieur Jumel, plutôt que
de nourrir l'angoisse et l'anxiété
des Français, aidez-nous à
mobiliser les entreprises, les
administrations, les collectivités
locales pour continuer dans la
baisse de leur consommation
d'énergie.
Aidez-nous à soutenir les salariés
d'EDF, qui sont au travail pour
augmenter notre production
d'électricité et pour sécuriser
nos stocks de gaz.
Aidez-nous à faire en sorte qu'au
niveau européen, on poursuive les
mesures que nous avons prises et
qui nous mettent en bien meilleure
situation qu'il y a neuf mois.
Cette ressource a disparu.
Elle ne nous est plus livrée par
la Russie.
Nous travaillons à protéger les
Français en protégeant leur accès
à l'énergie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Une seconde.
- Sébastien Jumel: Vous préparez
le scénario du pire et vous êtes
le pire des scénarios.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Patricia Lemoine pour le
groupe Renaissance.
- Patricia Lemoine: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Economie et des Finances.
Les derniers chiffres publiés par
l'INSEE font état d'une inflation
à 6,2% fin octobre, avec une
hausse des prix de 12%.
Si ces chiffres restent élevés,
l'action du gouvernement depuis
l'automne 2021 a permis de les
juguler, grâce à un dispositif qui
vise à limiter la hausse des prix
de l'énergie.
Il permet à notre pays d'afficher
une inflation plus faible que
celle de la zone euro, qui atteint
11,5% en moyenne, avec notamment
l'Allemagne et ses 11,6%, ou
l'Italie, qui grimpe à 12,6%.
Malgré tout, certains secteurs
sont davantage fragilisés.
C'est le cas de nos artisans
boulangers ou de nos bouchers qui
nous alertent sur leur situation.
La hausse vertigineuse du coût des
matières premières, farine de blé,
beurre, conjuguée à l'explosion du
coût de l'énergie, amène de
nombreux professionnels à
s'interroger sur la poursuite de
leur activité, pourtant vitale,
d'autant que vous nous avez
annoncé que le pic de l'inflation
n'était pas atteint.
Ils s'exposent à des situations
ubuesques avec des factures
d'énergie parfois multipliées par
20.
Je vous sais particulièrement
mobilisée pour accompagner tous
nos commerçants qui sont touchés
de plein fouet par cette crise.
Pouvez-vous nous faire part des
dernières mesures envisagées pour
répondre à l'ensemble de leurs
inquiétudes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Merci de rappeler que, grâce à
l'action du gouvernement, depuis
octobre 2021, la France garde le
taux d'inflation le plus faible de
la zone euro.
Nous avons protégé nos
compatriotes contre la flambée des
prix.
Pour ce qui est des boulangers, le
guichet d'aide est ouvert
aujourd'hui pour les factures
2022.
Mais ce qui les inquiète, c'est la
facture 2023.
Ils auront une réduction globale
de facture, en moyenne, de 20%,
pour tous les boulangers qui
auront droit à ce tarif
préférentiel d'électricité.
Nous allons proposer des offres
alternatives pour ces commerçants.
Nous voulons que la baisse des
prix soit indiquée dans le projet
de factures 2023, pour alléger
l'inquiétude des boulangers,
qu'ils sachent ce qu'ils vont
payer.
Ensuite, si nous voyons que, pour
un certain nombre de professions,
et je pense aux boulangers,
l'ensemble de ces mesures ne sont
pas suffisantes, nous sommes prêts
à étudier des mesures
complémentaires.
Nous ne laisserons pas tomber les
boulangers de France.
La seule chose que j'exclus, et
que les boulangers ont compris,
c'est une augmentation globale des
taxes sur toutes les entreprises.
Ce ne serait pas efficace.
Nous allons privilégier des
mesures efficaces, justes et
rapides.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Laurent
Panifous.
- Laurent Panifous: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs,
cette question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la Santé.
Souvent tabous, les troubles
psychiques concernent pourtant 13
millions de Français, soit presque
1 sur 5.
La pandémie de Covid n'a fait
qu'aggraver l'état de santé
mentale de la population.
La jeunesse n'a pas été épargnée.
La pédopsychiatrie manque de
moyens et d'effectifs.
Cette pénurie a des conséquences
dramatiques: allongement des
délais d'attente, risque de ne pas
détecter les troubles psychiques
chez les jeunes, et augmentation
des inégalités territoriales.
Dans l'Ariège, mon département,
ces structures qui
s'adonnent à ces problèmes sonnent
l'alerte.
Ils manquent de psychologues.
Faute de médecins, de
psychomotriciens, les prises en
charge sont compliquées.
Les soignants sont en grande
difficulté et tirent la sonnette
d'alarme.
Les enfants souffrent de troubles
psychiques et leurs parents sont
démunis.
Ils subissent tous les jours ce
manque d'accompagnement.
Les files d'attente s'allongent,
dans les centres médicaux.
Quelle est la stratégie du
gouvernement pour répondre
rapidement à la crise profonde que
traverse la pédopsychiatrie en
France?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun.
- François Braun: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, monsieur le
député Panifous, la
pédopsychiatrie et la prise en
charge de la santé de l'enfant est
une de mes priorités.
Vous l'avez signalé, les résultats
post-Covid montrent une
dégradation de la santé mentale
des jeunes, et en particulier des
jeunes filles.
Les assises de la santé mentale en
2021 nous ont permis de faire un
certain nombre d'actions dans ce
secteur.
Il y a le numéro national de
prévention du suicide.
Il y a eu des moyens financiers
dans les maisons des adolescents
et dans les centres
psychologiques.
Le dispositif Mon psy a permis de
rembourser 95.000 consultations,
déjà, y compris chez les enfants.
Pour autant, c'est insuffisant et
nous devons continuer à avancer.
Comme je m'y suis engagé, je lance
demain les assises de la pédiatrie
et de la santé de l'enfant, avec
une réunion de l'ensemble des
parties prenantes, la semaine
prochaine, pour une analyse, et
pour trouver des voies afin de
mettre en place des solutions
transversales.
Ces résultats seront disponibles à
partir du printemps, avec une
feuille de route pour les années à
venir, sur l'ensemble de la santé
de l'enfant, et, en particulier,
la santé mentale des enfants et
des adolescents.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Julie
Laernoes.
- Julie Laernoes: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la Transition
énergétique.
Fin août, le président affirmait
ne vouloir faire preuve d'aucune
faiblesse, d'aucun esprit de
compromissions, à l'égard de
l'agresseur russe.
En ce sens, depuis hier, plus
aucun navire transportant du
pétrole russe ne peut débarquer
dans un port européen.
Pourtant, d'autres navires russes
continuent à nous alimenter en
énergie.
Comme l'avait révélé Greenpeace,
des cargaisons remplies d'uranium
sont arrivées.
Elles sont arrivées à Dunkerque.
C'est la preuve du business qui se
poursuit avec la géante russe de
l'industrie nucléaire civile et
militaire.
Rosatom, c'est l'entreprise fondée
par Vladimir Poutine, pour servir
ses intérêts géopolitiques.
Rosatom, c'est la firme qui occupe
depuis des mois la centrale de
Zaporijia et qui fait subir des
traitements inhumains aux
employés.
Vous affirmiez que nous
n'importions pas d'uranium russe.
Pourtant, Framatome, la filiale
d'EDF concernée, a confirmé que le
commerce du nucléaire se poursuit
avec la Russie.
Les Français pouvaient-ils
l'ignorer?
Ces livraisons ont-elles pu être
faites sans votre autorisation?
Nous avons besoin de votre clarté.
Pouvez-vous lever l'opacité sur
cette question?
Quel est le montant exact et le
contenu de ces contrats?
Pourquoi le gouvernement ne met
pas un coup d'arrêt à ce commerce?
Le nucléaire semble bénéficier
d'un régime d'exception, même en
période de guerre.
N'est-ce pas la preuve de notre
dépendance totale à des puissances
étrangères pour faire tourner nos
centrales?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci,
madame la présidente, mesdames et
messieurs, madame Julie Laernoes.
Je veux remettre les choses en
perspective.
La France a négocié des sanctions
contre la Russie.
Elles visent à atteindre
l'économie russe et les décideurs
russes pour les ramener à la table
de négociations.
La France sera intransigeante sur
le respect de ces sanctions.
Sur la question de l'uranium, je
vais être claire.
La France n'est pas dépendante de
la Russie pour le fonctionnement
de son parc électronucléaire.
Comme je l'ai déjà dit, nous
n'importons pas, en 2022, d'uranium
naturel venant des mines russes,
pour les besoins du parc nucléaire
français.
Je veux également rappeler qu'au
niveau européen, d'autres pays
sont aujourd'hui dépendants de la
Russie.
La France peut jouer ce rôle de
reconstruire la souveraineté
européenne en matière de nucléaire
et d'uranium.
C'est un des enjeux sur lesquels
nous travaillons.
Nous avons diversifié, nous, nos
approvisionnements en matière
d'uranium naturel.
Nous sommes en train de construire
une filière complète sur la
question du recyclage de
l'uranium.
Nous serons demain le fer de lance
de cette souveraineté nucléaire,
dont je rappelle qu'elle nous
fournit aujourd'hui 70% de notre
électricité, une électricité
compétitive, bas carbone, qui
profite à l'ensemble des Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Alexandre
Sabatou.
- Alexandre Sabatou: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, cette
question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la Transition
énergétique.
Les semaines se suivent et se
ressemblent, au moment où la
France doit affronter la crise
énergétique majeure que vous avez
provoquée.
Marine Le Pen et les députés du
Rassemblement National n'ont eu de
cesse de vous avertir sur cette
situation catastrophique.
De semaine en semaine, vous nous
baladez, sans donner la moindre
réponse aux problèmes des
Français.
Le 25 novembre, la France et
l'Allemagne ont scellé un accord
d'échange.
La France devra livrer une partie
de ses réserves de gaz contre de
l'électricité allemande.
Un accord aux abords simples, mais
aux contours flous et imprécis.
En commission, dans l'hémicycle ou
à Matignon, lors d'entretiens avec
Marine Le Pen, vous refusez de
donner les conditions précises
d'application de cet accord.
La France livre déjà depuis
mi-octobre son gaz.
Quelles sont les conditions
économiques et financières de cet
accord, les obligations réelles de
l'Allemagne sur la livraison
d'électricité?
Des personnes chez EDF nous ont
alertés que les Allemands
prétextent régulièrement des
problèmes techniques pour ne pas
nous livrer d'électricité, quand
notre réseau est sous tension.
C'est scandaleux, quand on voit le
risque de coupures d'électricité
et l'explosion des coûts des
factures d'énergie.
Je pense aux bouchers, aux
charcutiers, qui ont manifesté la
semaine dernière, pour la première
fois depuis 30 ans.
Je pense à tous les commerçants,
les artisans.
Je pense à Flexico, une PME de ma
circonscription, fleuron français
de l'emballage.
C'est une cascade de faillites et
un chômage de masse que nous
allons devoir affronter.
Quelles garanties avons-nous que
l'électricité allemande ne soit
livrée que lorsque notre pays en
aura besoin?
Répondez à la représentation
nationale.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, monsieur le
député Sabatou, avec le RN, on
n'est jamais déçus, car quand il
s'agit d'agiter les peurs et
d'affoler les Français, on trouve
toujours fort à prendre.
Par contre, quand il faut, en
responsabilité, voter un projet de
loi qui permet de produire de
l'électricité bas carbone,
compétitive, on n'a plus de
répondant.
C'est le vrai visage du
Rassemblement National.
Pour répondre à votre question, si
je puis me permettre, premier
élément: il ne vous a pas échappé
que nous avons aujourd'hui rempli
au maximum nos stocks de gaz et
que nous soutenons l'ensemble de
l'Union Européenne en exportant du
gaz.
Nous le faisons aux conditions du
marché.
Vous m'interrogez sur l'accord
avec l'Allemagne.
Cela concerne ces exportations de
gaz.
Nous le faisons aux conditions du
marché.
Cela permet de garantir une
meilleure production d'électricité
sur l'ensemble de l'Europe.
20% de l'électricité européenne
est produite à base de gaz.
S'agissant des engagements de
l'Allemagne, je répète que
l'Allemagne s'est engagée à
prolonger l'utilisation de leurs
centrales nucléaires qui sont
aujourd'hui en base, qui
permettent de sécuriser les
interconnexions avec la France.
Nous avons arraché cet accord avec
le président de la République et
la Première ministre.
Cela nous permet, là encore,
d'affronter dans les meilleures
conditions l'hiver.
Vous voyez que l'Europe, cela nous
permet d'être plus fort pour faire
face à la crise énergétique, mais
aussi de garantir du gaz et de
l'électricité aux Français dans
les mois qui viennent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Didier
Lemaire.
- Didier Lemaire: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur, chers collègues,
comme beaucoup de nos concitoyens,
je suis inquiet des coupures
d'électricité à venir, qui peuvent
durer 2 minutes jusqu'à 2 heures.
On ne peut pas se contenter
d'espérer qu'il ne se passe pas de
drame durant ces coupures.
En matière de gestion de crise, la
chance n'a pas sa place et la
prévention reste son meilleur
atout.
J'ai lu avec attention la note des
préfets de zone.
Les préfets sont en train de
travailler à la mise en place de
dispositifs adaptés, au cas où les
numéros d'urgence ne pourraient
pas fonctionner.
Il se trouve, et je m'en réjouis,
que les maires sont à nouveau au
coeur du dispositif.
Je pense qu'on peut trouver des
solutions locales aux enjeux
nationaux.
Demander aux maires de prendre
part aux cellules de crise, leur
demander de mettre en place des
modes opératoires relatifs à la
sécurité civile...
On sait qu'il existe beaucoup de
dispositifs qui sont soit
méconnus, soit inappropriés au fil
du temps.
La gestion de crise ne s'improvise
pas.
Comment comptez-vous communiquer
auprès de nos concitoyens sur cet
événement et comment comptez-vous
accompagner les maires pour faire
face à ces difficultés?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Monsieur le député, sous
l'autorité de la Première
ministre, les préfets de la
République, avec les policiers,
les gendarmes et les pompiers, se
préparent à un scénario qui
mènerait le délestage à empêcher
une partie du fonctionnement
classique de la vie des Français.
Les préfets ont rendu leur copie à
madame la Première ministre.
Dans chacun des départements, nous
connaissons les édifices publics
qui sont ceux qui permettent la
protection des Français: les
commissariats, les gendarmeries,
les centres d'appels du 17 ou du
18.
L'appel des Français dans les
numéros d'urgence doit être le
112.
Ils le savent.
Il existe déjà des zones blanches,
aujourd'hui, qui empêchent nos
concitoyens d'appeler ce numéro,
ou des moments particuliers, comme
nous avons vécu il y a quelques
semaines, lorsqu'il y a eu une
crise d'un opérateur téléphonique.
Nous avons équipé en groupes
électrogènes tous les sites du
ministère de l'Intérieur.
Nous allons renforcer les brigades
de gendarmerie et les
commissariats de police, pour
pouvoir être, en cas de zones
blanches, au rendez-vous de nos
concitoyens, soit directement
auprès des élus, soit en ouvrant
tous les lieux de service public.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Hugues Ratenon.
- Jean-Hugues Ratenon: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
des Outre-mer.
Je suis interpellé sur le prix des
billets d'avion.
Vous nous avez promis des
solutions.
Vous aviez promis des solutions
sur les prix de la téléphonie et
d'Internet.
Sur les prix des loyers,
également.
Vous nous aviez promis des
solutions sur les prix des
médicaments, des banques.
Trouvez-vous normal qu'en
comparaison
dans une grande surface, à la
Réunion et à Ivry-sur-Seine, le
lait en poudre coûte 40% plus cher
à la Réunion?
Les 500 grammes de spaghettis, ils
sont plus chers de 40% chez nous.
Le paquet de 10 lames de rasoir
coûte 3,29 euros ici et il coûte
jusqu'à 7 euros en outre-mer.
Les protections hygiéniques sont
86% plus chers.
Le compte n'y est pas.
Votre montagne de solution
accouche d'une souris.
Vous faites mine d'ignorer que le
pouvoir d'achat, c'est aussi les
revenus.
Rien sur les minima sociaux, rien
pour les personnes âgées et
retraitées.
Pensez-vous qu'en outre-mer, on
peut vivre avec ce SMIC?
Vous avez encore 48 heures pour
revoir votre copie.
Allez-vous le faire?
Cessez d'abandonner les outre-mer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-François Carenco, ministre
délégué chargé des Outre-mer.
- Jean-François Carenco: Nous
étions engagés, avec Gérald
Darmanin, sur ces questions de
pouvoir d'achat.
La priorité première était de
parvenir à des accords de
modération des coûts sur les
produits de grande consommation.
Des chartes territorialisées ont
été signées dans tous les
territoires concernés.
Les acteurs économiques, et, pour
la première fois, les
collectivités, ont joué le jeu au
niveau territorial.
Je vous rappelle que ce sont elles
qui fixent le niveau des coûts.
Il faut noter que les recettes
d'octroi de mer, payées par les
consommateurs, ont augmenté.
Elles ont augmenté de 11%.
Nous avons attendu les décisions
des assemblées délibérantes en la
matière.
Peut-être que cela a avancé moins
vite que prévu, mais dès le 8
décembre, nous allons présenter
des résultats sur cette question
de bouclier qualité-prix.
Cela concerne le multimédia, les
services automobiles, la
téléphonie.
Il y a encore des progrès à faire,
mais juste un mot sur ce que vous
avez évoqué.
La solution a été trouvée.
Dorénavant, les taxes seront
payées uniquement au-delà de 400
euros, au lieu de 200 euros,
auparavant.
Merci aux collectivités pour
lesquelles vous travaillez de nous
aider.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Bertrand
Sorre.
- Bertrand Sorre: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'Etat chargée de
l'Economie sociale et solidaire et
de la Vie associative.
Depuis 1985, l'Organisation des
Nations Unies a proclamé la
journée du 5 décembre Journée
internationale du bénévolat et du
volontaire.
Je tiens ici à saluer les 20
millions de bénévoles associatifs
pour leur dévouement et pour leur
engagement.
Applaudissements
Car nous le savons, les
associations, les bénévoles et les
volontaires sont le coeur battant
de notre République.
A cet effet, vous avez commandé un
sondage en vue de cette Journée
mondiale, pour mesurer
l'engagement des Français.
Nous pouvons dire qu'ils ont du
coeur.
Il en ressort que 49% de nos
concitoyens se déclarent engagés
dans une association locale ou
nationale.
Les associations préférées des
Français sont notamment les Restos
du Coeur, la SPA, la Croix-Rouge,
la Ligue contre le cancer ou les
banques alimentaires.
Vous les avez d'ailleurs reçues
hier.
Vous avez annoncé le futur
lancement des assises de la
simplification administrative.
Il y a trop de paperasse dans la
vie associative.
Souvent, les petites structures se
heurtent à cette difficulté et
leurs bénévoles déplorent cette
lourdeur.
Lors du précédent quinquennat,
sous l'impulsion de Sarah El
Haïry, des mesures pour faciliter
la vie de nos associations ont été
adoptées par la majorité.
Mais des simplifications sont
encore à mettre en oeuvre.
Ce sondage révèle l'attachement de
nos concitoyens à leur territoire
et l'importance que joue le
maillage territorial du tissu
associatif.
Face à ces constats, les
politiques publiques en faveur de
la vie associative doivent être au
rendez-vous.
Pouvez-vous nous faire savoir
quelle sera votre feuille de route
pour ce nouveau quinquennat?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Marlène
Schiappa.
- Marlène Schiappa: Merci.
Monsieur le député Sorre, je vous
remercie pour votre question.
Hier, c'était la Journée mondiale
des bénévoles et des volontaires.
Le président de la République
s'est exprimé en soutien,
vis-à-vis de ces bénévoles,
puisqu'une grande part des
Français sont bénévoles.
L'étude à laquelle vous faites
référence montre que près de 1
Français sur 2 est engagé auprès
d'une association.
Cela peut vouloir dire être
bénévole ou donateur.
A l'approche de la fin de l'année,
il reste quelques semaines pour
faire des dons aux associations.
Les associations plébiscitées par
les Français sont les Restos du
Coeur, la SPA, la Croix-Rouge, la
Ligue contre le cancer et les
banques alimentaires.
Nous étions avec la Première
ministre et le ministre des
Solidarités auprès des banques
alimentaires pour dévoiler un
fonds de 60 millions d'euros en
soutien à ces associations
engagées.
Nous souhaitons, dans la lignée de
ma prédécesseure, Sarah El Haïry,
poursuivre ce travail de
simplification.
Je remercie les députés qui sont
venus décorer des bénévoles
d'associations, mais aussi les
ministres.
Ils étaient présents.
On veut dématérialiser et aller
vers un guichet unique, pour qu'il
y ait moins de paperasse, afin de
numériser, aller vers des
solutions plus simples pour les
subventions, afin d'alléger la
charge mentale des dirigeants
associatifs.
Merci pour votre engagement.
Je suis à la disposition des
députés qui souhaitent saluer et
valoriser les associations.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Louis Bricout.
- Jean-Louis Bricout: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
la Transition énergétique.
Madame la ministre, nous sommes
bons derniers en Europe en matière
de déploiement des énergies
renouvelables.
Pourtant, et c'est là tout le
paradoxe, certains territoires
sont déjà trop abîmés par
l'éolien.
Il nous faut produire plus
d'énergie décarbonée.
Il nous faut répondre à la demande
croissante des usages électriques,
chacun sait que le nucléaire ne
pourra pas y répondre
immédiatement.
Nous ne pourrons pas accroître la
production d'énergie verte sans
travailler à son acceptabilité.
Dans les Hauts-de-France, une
éolienne de plus, c'est souvent
une éolienne de trop.
Cette transition, vous ne pourrez
la faire sans les territoires.
Sans respecter les élus, sans
respecter leur population, sans
respecter leur projet, sans
respecter leur paysage.
Vous proposez dans votre projet de
loi un dispositif de
planification, mais celui-ci est
encore incomplet.
Certes, les élus pourront définir
des zones d'accélération et des
zones d'exclusion.
Qu'en sera-t-il des petites
communes dépourvues de PLU pour
annoncer ces zonages?
Comment faire une répartition
harmonieuse des éoliennes sur
notre territoire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Agnès Pannier-Runacher,
ministre de la Transition
énergétique.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Monsieur
le député, merci pour votre
question, qui permet d'évoquer le
système de planification
énergétique que nous sommes en
train de co-construire.
Je tiens à vous remercier pour
votre engagement pour développer
ces énergies renouvelables, car
vous êtes bien placé pour
connaître la situation de
saturation sur certaines
localisations du territoire des
Hauts-de-France.
Vous êtes aussi à la manoeuvre
pour faire en sorte que l'on
déploie toutes les énergies
renouvelables: les éoliennes
marines, le biométhane, la
géothermie et le photovoltaïque.
C'est toutes ces énergies
renouvelables que nous voulons
aujourd'hui accélérer.
Cette planification prévoit un
principe très simple.
D'abord, ce sont les maires qui
définissent les zones où il
veulent accélérer les énergies
renouvelables.
Ce sont également les maires qui
définissent les zones où il vont
limiter l'implantation d'énergie
renouvelable.
Grâce à cette planification, nous
leur redonnons les moyens de
définir ces zones et d'être les
derniers décideurs pour porter un
avis conforme sur ce zonage.
Vous le savez, nous prenons en
compte dans les objectifs de
développement des énergies
renouvelables.
C'est à la fois l'importance du
déploiement des énergies
renouvelables sur un territoire en
termes de puissance installée et
de production, mais c'est aussi
l'impact sur le paysage.
Nous l'avons pris en compte.
Vous posez la question des
communes qui n'ont pas de
documents d'urbanisme.
Pour celles-ci, dans le cadre du
schéma départemental que nous
allons mettre en oeuvre et qui
sera défini à chaque département.
Elles bénéficieront du soutien de
l'Etat.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Jean-Louis Bricout?
- Jean-Louis Bricout: C'est bien
gentil, mais c'est incomplet.
On vous a demandé la définition
d'un taux d'effort sur les
territoires ou pour la mise en
place de Magnus dans les appels
d'offres dans des zones saturées.
Il reste beaucoup de pistes à
explorer.
Le vote de notre groupe se fera au
regard de votre niveau
d'acceptation de nos propositions.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, mon cher collègue.
La parole est à madame Sandra
Regol pour le groupe écologiste.
- Sandra Regol: Je ne veux plus
d'ici la fin de l'année avoir des
hommes et des femmes à la rue."
C'est ce qu'avait déclaré Emmanuel
Macron en 2017.
4 millions de personnes mal
logées, 600 morts chaque année
dans les rues.
Associations et collectivités
pallient les manques de l'Etat,
mais elles agissent seules, sans
l'aide du gouvernement.
A Strasbourg, malgré une
intervention volontariste de la
ville, les moyens d'une mairie ne
peuvent pas suffire à une crise
humanitaire.
La mise à l'abri relève des
compétences de l'Etat.
Pourtant, monsieur le ministre, la
préfecture ne laisse aucun répit.
Elle veut cacher cette misère loin
du centre-ville.
En réponse, la maire de Strasbourg
intente une action en
responsabilité de l'Etat.
Je voulais lui dire merci de le
faire pour toutes et tous.
Merci de le faire pour refus de la
fatalité que vous n'avez pas.
C'est notre histoire.
Si nous oublions qui nous sommes,
que nous reste-t-il?
Le nombre de personnes sans-abri
explose partout.
Des centaines de jeunes, des
enfants à la rue, dénoncent leurs
conditions d'inhumanité dans
lesquelles ils sont gérés.
Alors, monsieur le ministre, cher
gouvernement, comptez-vous laisser
vos préfets continuer à cacher la
misère ou nous aider à sauver des
vies?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Klein, ministre de la Ville et du
logement.
- Olivier Klein: Madame la
présidente, madame la députée
Sandra Regol, vous parlez de
fraternité, de dignité, la
première des dignités, c'est de ne
pas essayer de faire un coup
politique sur une situation qui
est inacceptable et inhumaine.
La situation de Strasbourg, nous
la connaissons depuis trop
longtemps.
La situation de Strasbourg et de
ce camp est une situation
insupportable.
Madame, l'Etat propose des
solutions, a proposé des solutions
à Strasbourg, a travaillé avec la
ville de Strasbourg...
Oui, madame...
Laissez-moi répondre.
L'Etat a proposé des solutions.
Les familiers ont refusé.
Celles qui les ont acceptées ont
été remplacées par d'autres
familles, car la maire de
Strasbourg a refusé d'assumer ses
responsabilités.
Il y a un droit particulier en
Alsace et en Moselle.
La possibilité de substitution de
l'Etat n'existe pas.
C'était à la maire de lancer les
procédures d'évacuation.
Elle a été condamnée par le
tribunal administratif pour
atteinte à la dignité humaine.
Qui est défaillant, madame?
Le camp a été évacué ce matin.
Que de temps perdu!
48 familles ont été mises à
l'abri.
Qui est défaillant?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame Sandra
Regol?
- Sandra Regol: Neuf condamnations
par la Cour européenne des droits
de l'homme.
C'est ce que la France a eu sous
Emmanuel Macron pour son inaction
face aux problèmes de logement.
Des conditions d'existence
inhumaines et dégradantes pour les
sans-abri.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Olivier Klein: Sur l'action du
gouvernement et de la Première
ministre, nous avons maintenu les
places d'hébergement d'urgence à
un niveau jamais atteint: à plus
de 200.000 places.
19.000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence dans le Haut-Rhin.
Nous agissons tous les jours.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Katiana
Levavasseur pour le groupe
Rassemblement National.
- Katiana Levavasseur: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre...
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la Transition
énergétique.
Depuis plusieurs mois, le thème de
la hausse des énergies s'est
imposé au sein de cet hémicycle.
Une fois encore, je me dois d'y
revenir.
Pourquoi?
Car la situation ne s'améliore
pas.
Ce week-end encore, je me faisais
interpeller dans une rue de la
part de chefs d'entreprise sur les
difficultés qui sont les leurs à
l'approche de Noël.
Avez-vous pu apporter des réponses
satisfaisantes?
Beaucoup de gens attendent des
mesures de protection.
Beaucoup n'en bénéficient pas.
La période des fêtes, normalement
synonyme de hausse des ventes et
d'embauches de personnel, approche
à grands pas.
Ces hommes et ces femmes qui font
vivre nos territoires grâce à
leurs commerces de proximité se
voient contraints de revoir leurs
calculs prévisionnels à la baisse.
De nombreux gérants m'ont confié
qu'il leur sera impossible
d'engager de nouvelles recrues,
comme c'est le cas généralement
durant cette période de l'année.
Pire encore, certains envisagent
de mettre une partie de leurs
salariés en activité partielle.
La hausse des coûts de
l'électricité oblige les gérants
de PME et de TPE à réduire leur
activité, ce qui entraîne des
pertes de chiffre d'affaires et
des conséquences sur les employés.
Vous qui avez de grands projets
pour l'emploi en France, vous qui
voulez retarder l'âge de départ à
la retraite, vous qui voulez
diminuer la durée d'indemnisation
de l'assurance chômage, quelles
sont vos propositions concernant
cette énième problématique
touchant les commerçants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Olivia
Grégoire, ministre déléguée
chargée des Petites et Moyennes
entreprises, du Commerce, de
l'artisanat et du tourisme.
- Olivia Grégoire: Madame la
députée, merci pour vos questions.
Vos questions sont nombreuses.
Celles des commerçants, des
artisans, sont nombreuses aussi.
Je ne vais pas lire mon papier,
mais répondre précisément.
Est-ce que j'ai reçu les bouchers
depuis bientôt trois mois?
Oui, madame!
Est-ce que nous avons regardé
leurs factures avec précision pour
regarder ce qu'il en est et voir
la réalité des faits?
Oui.
Entre l'augmentation du
mégawatt/heure, sur la facture, il
y a parfois des différences.
Ces factures sont compliquées à
comprendre.
J'ai moi-même des difficultés.
Je vous prends chacune et chacun
au défi de lire avec dextérité
l'ensemble des factures.
On voit des acteurs, des
commerçants, des artisans, qui
sont en partie aidés.
Les aides commencent à être
distribuées.
On voit des commerçants qui sont
au coeur des augmentations de
l'emploi.
Il ne vous a pas échappé que nous
avons continué à avoir des bons
chiffres.
Nous avons un chômage qui continue
à baisser.
Nos PME sont au coeur des
recrutements.
Il y a beaucoup de questionnements
sur 2023.
Vous m'avez parlé des bouchers.
Oui, je les ai reçus.
Est-ce qu'on va trouver des
solutions?
Oui, madame!
Est-ce que je les reçois un par
un?
Oui, et c'est bien normal.
Vous devriez en faire de même.
Ca vous éviterait de dire des
erreurs.
On va passer cet hiver ensemble.
Ils recrutent.
C'est compliqué.
Sur l'assurance chômage, ils n'ont
qu'un mot: "Merci de légiférer,
merci d'être courageux, de
condamner les abandons de postes
et d'encourager à reprendre du
boulot parce qu'on veut
embaucher."
C'est ce qu'ils disent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Philippe
Fait pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Philippe Fait: Ma question
s'adresse à madame Geneviève
Darrieussecq.
Ce samedi 3 décembre, nous avons
célébré la Journée internationale
des personnes handicapées.
Une journée créée en 1992.
30 ans pour promouvoir la question
de la promotion des handicaps.
Pour autant, je souhaitais aborder
aujourd'hui un sujet sur lequel je
suis engagé: le handicap et
l'égalité femme-homme.
A l'occasion de la 26e édition de
la semaine européenne pour
l'emploi des personnes
handicapées, certaines personnes
ont mis en exergue une situation
inégalitaire systémique.
Près de 80% des femmes en
situation de handicap déclarent
s'occuper des tâches domestiques
et familiales elles-mêmes.
Ce qu'on appelle la charge mentale
est une problématique en France.
Les femmes en situation de
handicap n'échappent pas à la
règle.
Il faut ajouter ce que révèlent
ces deux études: les violences
subies au sein du couple.
Une femme handicapée sur quatre
indique avoir déjà subi des
violences conjugales.
Un chiffre bien supérieur à celui
mesuré auprès des hommes et des
femmes handicapés.
Une femme handicapée sur cinq
déclare avoir déjà été violée.
Nous sommes au-dessus des chiffres
concernant l'ensemble des femmes:
1/10.
La situation de vulnérabilité
physique et psychologique des
femmes en situation de handicap
les expose davantage aux
comportements de prédation.
Quel est votre sentiment sur cette
problématique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Geneviève Darrieussecq,
ministre déléguée chargée des
Personnes handicapées.
- Geneviève Darrieussecq: Mesdames
et messieurs les députés, monsieur
le député Philippe Fait, je vous
remercie de mettre le focus sur le
handicap et sur les femmes en
situation de handicap, sur
l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes et sur les violences faites
aux femmes en situation de
handicap.
Les femmes en situation de
handicap sont 2 fois plus victimes
que les autres de violences
sexuelles.
C'est glaçant.
Etre une femme et être en
situation de handicap, c'est la
double peine.
Je ne peux pas et nous ne pouvons
pas l'accepter.
Nous travaillons avec Isabelle
Rome
à déployer des mesures concrètes
sur le terrain.
La détection des violences demande
d'aller vers ces femmes.
Un travail de sensibilisation sur
la vie affective et sexuelle et
sur la question du consentement et
de la violence est mené.
Il y a la formation des
professionnels des secteurs
médico-sociaux: repérer les
signaux de violence est essentiel.
Un dispositif mis en oeuvre dans
trois régions répond à ces sujets.
Je souhaite qu'il soit généralisé
dans notre pays.
L'égalité homme-femme passe par
l'accès à l'autonomie.
Nous devons veiller à l'accès
également, à la formation, à
l'emploi.
Par l'autonomie, les femmes en
situation de handicap, comme
toutes les femmes, seront plus
indépendantes et plus en sécurité.
Vous évoquez le sujet...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Andrée
Taurinya pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Andrée Taurinya: Madame la
présidente, le madame la Première
ministre, la justice ne fait
aucune référence à la nationalité
des enfants en France, mais force
est de constater que les mineurs
non accompagnés ne sont pas
traités de la même manière que les
autres.
Les autorités veulent démasquer
les faux mineurs voulant profiter
de l'aide à l'enfance.
Après un parcours migratoire
traumatisant, ils croient arriver
au pays des droits de l'homme,
mais découvrent celui de Kafka.
Ils doivent prouver leur âge, mais
on remet en cause la validité de
leurs papiers.
S'ils les ont perdus durant leur
périple, on les empêche de se
mettre en lien avec leur famille.
Ils sont remis à la rue par l'Etat
français, livrés à eux-mêmes.
A Ivry, ils sont 500 dans un
campement, avec cinq toilettes et
six robinets d'eau.
Depuis vendredi, 300 se sont
installés devant le Conseil d'Etat
dans le froid et toujours en
attente d'hébergement.
12 ont dû être évacués par les
pompiers.
Malgré les demandes des élus
locaux, sans proposer de solutions
d'hébergement pérennes, le préfet
a donné l'ordre d'évacuation.
Elle aurait lieu demain au petit
matin, de manière inhumaine, comme
cette fameuse nuit de novembre
2020 place de la République.
Prenez l'engagement solennel
devant la représentation nationale
que votre gouvernement coopère de
manière transparente dans le cadre
de cette enquête.
Quand prendrez-vous les mesures
qui s'imposent pour que la France
respecte la Convention
internationale des droits de
l'enfant, qui édicte la
présomption de minorité?
Combien de temps l'Etat
laissera-t-il ces jeunes à la rue
et dans le froid?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Charlotte
Caubel, secrétaire d'Etat chargée
de l'Enfance.
- Charlotte Caubel: Madame la
députée, le principe de
présomption de minorité est
totalement respecté dans nos pays.
Dans notre pays, pardonnez-moi.
Effectivement, le principe selon
lequel un mineur, tant qu'il est
isolé sur notre territoire, doit
être protégé est un principe
formel au nom de la Convention
internationale des droits de
l'enfant.
Simplement, nous le savons, dans
ces dispositifs de protection de
l'enfance, des personnes se
prétendant comme mineurs non
accompagnés, qui sont majeurs,
viennent demander une protection.
C'est une réalité.
Nous ne pouvons concevoir que dans
nos structures, des majeurs
côtoient des mineurs.
C'est une question de protection
des mineurs.
Notre dispositif est très clair.
Ce sont les départements qui sont
en charge de l'aide.
Le principe de minorité est
respecté et les droits
fondamentaux des enfants sont
respectés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Madame Andrée Taurinya?
- Andrée Taurinya: Vous esquivez.
Faudra-t-il attendre des morts
pour que vous réagissiez?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame la
ministre?
- Charlotte Caubel: C'est trop
facile de faire ce type
d'accusation.
18.000 mineurs sont hébergés
aujourd'hui par les départements
de France chaque année.
Ca fait presque...
Les mineurs non accompagnés sont
protégés en France et nous leur
assurons la protection
internationale qui est due par nos
conventions.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-Charles Larsonneur
pour le groupe Horizons.
- Jean-Charles Larsonneur: Ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
la Santé.
Nous sommes confrontés à une
triple épidémie: Covid, grippe et
bronchiolite, sans précédent
depuis 10 ans pour cette dernière.
Une triple épidémie qui touche
tous les Français et qui met sous
forte tension
notre système de santé.
Un plan blanc national a été
déclenché le 10 novembre dernier
et est décliné dans de nombreux
établissements et territoires,
singulièrement dans l'ouest de la
France, dans l'Ille-et-Vilaine.
Tous souhaitent passer les fêtes
de fin d'année de manière sûre et
sereine, en protégeant nos proches
et les plus fragiles autour de
nous.
Nous avons été unanimement
solidaires autour de nos soignants
depuis le début de la pandémie
Covid.
Nous n'avons pas changé et je
crois que nous portons une
responsabilité collective pour
nous protéger et soulager nos
soignants, auquel je veux rendre
un hommage appuyé.
Il n'est pas inutile de rappeler
que la vaccination est efficace
pour se prémunir des formes graves
de Covid et de grippe.
Ma question porte sur les gestes
barrières et sur le port du
masque.
C'est un geste simple qui nous
protège, qui protège les autres et
réduit drastiquement les risques
de transmission.
Un geste simple, mais que nous
sommes trop nombreux à délaisser,
bien souvent parce que nous avons
perdu le réflexe d'avoir un masque
à portée de main.
Ne peut-on sensibiliser davantage
à travers les campagnes à la
télévision, à la radio, sur
l'utilité de porter le masque?
Vous l'avez dit, vous n'aurez pas
la main tremblante s'il faut
prendre nos responsabilités.
Est-il pas temps de rendre le port
du masque obligatoire dans les
transports en commun, au travail
ou dans les centres commerciaux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à François Braun, ministre de la
Santé et de la Prévention.
- François Braun: Monsieur le
député Larsonneur, la Covid-19
continue à tuer tous les jours des
personnes fragiles ou non dans
notre pays.
Le taux d'incidence au cours de
ces derniers jours a augmenté de
40%, ce qui montre cette
augmentation de circulation du
virus.
Cette circulation arrive dans des
circonstances nouvelles et
particulières.
Nouvelles parce qu'il y a une
triple épidémie actuellement.
Une épidémie de bronchiolite, et
nous n'en sommes pas encore au
sommet.
Il y a une épidémie de grippe qui
concerne plus de la moitié du
territoire national.
Il y a cette reprise de l'épidémie
Covid.
Le tout arrive sur un système de
santé en difficulté, à bout de
souffle.
Cela ne facilite pas les choses.
La situation actuelle est d'autant
plus insupportable que nous avons
les moyens de nous protéger et de
protéger les Français.
Ces moyens, c'est d'abord la
vaccination.
La vaccination reste notre arme de
protection massive face au virus,
en particulier la grippe et le
Covid.
Cette vaccination est
insuffisamment développée.
Elle est de l'ordre de 20% pour
les plus de 80 ans.
C'est très en deçà de ce que nous
avons fait dans les campagnes
précédentes.
La vaccination contre la grippe
est inférieure par rapport à
l'année dernière.
Ce sont les personnes les plus
fragiles qu'il faut protéger.
Je tiens à rappeler ici que toute
personne qui souhaite se faire
vacciner peut se faire vacciner.
Il est important que ce soit les
plus fragiles qui soient vaccinés
en premiers, mais d'autres
personnes, et en particulier leur
entourage, doivent se faire
vacciner pour les protéger.
Dans tous les lieux où il y a de
la promiscuité, j'invite les
Français à porter le masque de
façon systématique pour se
protéger.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Marcelin
Nadeau pour le groupe démocrate et
républicain.
- Marcelin Nadeau: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des
Sceaux, ministre de la Justice.
Monsieur le ministre, la pollution
durable par le chlordécone en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique
constitue, par son ampleur et sa
persistance, un enjeu sanitaire
environnemental, agricole,
économique et sociale pour les
Antilles.
Or, en plus de ces aspects
énoncés, force est de constater
qu'il s'agit aussi et désormais
d'un scandale judiciaire.
Le 24 novembre dernier, après 16
années de batailles juridiques, le
parquet de Paris a préconisé un
non-lieu dans l'affaire du crime
nommé chlordécone.
Dans ce dossier, le ministère
public préconise le silence et
l'impunité sous couvert de
non-lieu.
La boucle est donc bouclée.
La justice ne peut condamner
l'Etat, et l'Etat demande à la
justice d'absoudre les divers
responsables de ce crime
d'empoisonnement.
Dans ce jeu de couverture
réciproque, se dégage un fort
sentiment de mépris à l'égard des
peuples empoisonnés de Martinique
et de Guadeloupe, dont les
populations, selon Santé publique
France, seraient contaminées à
responsables non coupables comme
dans l'affaire du sang contaminé,
alors que près d'un demi-million
de personnes demeurent
empoisonnées.
Pour vous, ça semble ne pas être
grave.
Il est vrai qu'on est aux
Antilles!
Aux Antilles où on a souvent le
sentiment d'être au temps des
colonies.
Alors, monsieur le ministre, ma
question est simple: peut-on se
satisfaire d'une responsabilité
morale pour un empoisonnement de
cette ampleur sans que la justice
passe?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Jean-François
Carenco, ministre délégué chargé
des Outre-mer.
- Jean-François Karanco: De toutes
les façons, ce gouvernement ne
commande pas les positions de la
justice, et nous respectons
l'indépendance de la justice,
notamment dans les Antilles.
Je peux y aller?
Merci.
Par contre, il m'appartient de
rappeler que le président de la
République est le premier à avoir
reconnu la responsabilité de
l'Etat dans la pollution du
chlordécone.
Sous son impulsion, des avancées
fortes ont été obtenues:
reconnaissance du cancer de la
prostate comme maladie
professionnelle, les analyses
gratuites du taux de chlordécone
dans le sang pour toute la
population, analyse gratuite des
sols pour les agriculteurs et
particuliers.
Nous cultivons des produits sains,
y compris sur les terres
contaminées.
Tout ceci a été présenté lors
d'une réunion le 4 novembre.
Il fallait y être.
Le colloque scientifique se
déroulera la semaine prochaine en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique.
Il y aura des échanges
constructifs sur le chlordécone.
Sur ce sujet comme sur tant
d'autres, arrêtons les polémiques
inutiles.
Avançons au profit des populations
antillaises.
Je sais pouvoir compter sur vous
comme vous savez le faire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Marine Hamelet pour le
groupe du Rassemblement National.
- Marine Hamelet: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Ndiaye.
Je suis la porte-parole des
professeurs du lycée de Montauban,
dans le Lot-et-Garonne.
Les professeurs veulent faire
respecter la loi sur la laïcité.
Je vais vous lire l'extrait d'une
lettre.
"Aujourd'hui, l'école républicaine
mène la bataille la plus cruciale
de son histoire.
Face à l'hydre islamiste, les
enseignants de ce pays sont seuls,
lâchés par la hiérarchie et
maîtrisés par ceux qui fournissent
des circulaires leur expliquant
comment tenir la tranchée, quand
ils désertent le champ de
bataille.
L'école devient aujourd'hui un
espace de ségrégation pour ceux
qui appliquent le droit à la
ressemblance."
Après les paroles, il est grand
temps de passer aux actes.
Cette professeure a subi des
pressions et elle est désespérée,
au point d'avoir perdu la
vocation.
Son cas n'est pas isolé.
L'offensive du communautarisme
islamiste s'est considérablement
accélérée depuis la rentrée de
septembre.
Vous le savez.
Qu'attendez-vous pour agir?
Ne me répondez pas qu'il faut
porter plainte.
Cela n'a pas évité à monsieur
Samuel Paty la mort.
Combien de Samuel Paty faudra-t-il
pour que vous preniez la mesure de
notre situation?
Ma question est simple.
Qu'envisagez-vous pour faire
respecter la laïcité dans nos
écoles et assurer la protection
des agents publics?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, madame la
députée Hamelet, les chiffres de
signalement des atteintes à la
laïcité pour le mois de novembre
ne sont pas encore tout à fait
consolidés mais je peux vous
indiquer que les premiers éléments
marquent une baisse extrêmement
conséquente.
Je tiens à rappeler que, face à
l'augmentation des chiffres
d'atteinte à la laïcité au mois
d'octobre, j'ai mis en place un
plan de laïcité qui repose sur
quatre axes: la sanction
systématique et graduée des
comportements répréhensibles des
élèves concernés.
Ensuite, la protection et le
soutien au personnel, y compris
les dépôts de plaintes, mais aussi
la protection fonctionnelle.
Enfin, l'appui aux actions des
chefs d'établissement et le
renforcement de la formation des
personnels.
Ce sont des mesures concrètes,
basées sur un triptyque: le
dialogue, la sanction et la
protection, si nécessaire.
Cette méthode a prouvé son
efficacité dans le lycée que vous
citez, le lycée de Montauban.
Alors qu'une vingtaine d'élèves
venait en abaya, en début d'année,
grâce aux sanctions, quand le
dialogue avec les élèves et les
familles n'a pas suffi, beaucoup
de solutions ont été trouvées.
Il faut trouver les moyens pour
maintenir les élèves dans la
République.
C'est le rôle de l'école et du
ministère de l'Education
nationale.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame Hamelet?
- Marine Hamelet: Vous l'avez dit,
les problèmes perdurent.
Il faut prendre des mesures
supplémentaires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
ministre?
- Pap Ndiaye: Je viens de vous
indiquer qu'on observe une baisse
significative des atteintes à la
laïcité pour le mois de novembre,
en particulier pour ce qui
concerne le port de vêtements et
de signes à intentions
religieuses.
La laïcité, c'est une liberté.
C'est l'émancipation par le
savoir.
Elle n'est pas faite pour des
effets de manches politiciens.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Raphaël
Schellenberger.
- Raphaël Schellenberger: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, vous
soumettez au parlement, de façon
successive, des textes sur
l'énergie qui ne sont toujours que
des dispositifs d'ajustement.
Vous n'avez jamais fixé un cap
clair.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons des
craintes.
Il y a deux semaines, lors de
votre déclaration sur la politique
énergétique de la France, vous
avez indiqué travailler à
identifier les réacteurs
nucléaires qui seront fermés.
Pourtant, il nous faudra tout
mettre en oeuvre pour porter notre
parc nucléaire au-delà de 60 ans.
Nous craignons que vous n'ayez pas
changé de cap par rapport à la
programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie que vous aviez évoquée
quand vous étiez ministre de
l'Energie, qui prévoyait la
réduction de 50% de la part du
nucléaire dans notre mix
électrique.
Avez-vous pris en compte le
discours de Belfort du candidat
Macron et changé d'avis?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci.
La vision de notre politique
énergétique, vous la connaissez.
Elle a été exprimée lors d'un
débat qui a été conduit ici par
notre Première ministre.
Elle a été expliquée dans le
discours de Belfort du président
de la République, le 8 février.
Elle repose sur un triptyque: la
sobriété, l'efficacité
énergétique.
Il s'agit de diminuer notre
consommation d'énergie finale.
40% de réduction, c'est le
scénario voulu.
Deuxième objectif: développer les
énergies renouvelables.
Ce sont celles dont nous pouvons
avoir besoin dans les années qui
viennent.
Elles peuvent être rapidement
développées, elles sont bas
carbone et vont permettre de
baisser le prix que payent les
Français et les entreprises.
Troisième objectif: relancer la
filière nucléaire.
Il n'y a aucune ambiguïté sur ce
sujet.
Vous le savez, le débat concernant
la mise en place des deux premiers
réacteurs est lancé.
Nous travaillons avec EDF et le
nouveau patron d'EDF, afin
d'anticiper la mise en oeuvre de
mesures d'excellence
opérationnelle sur le parc
existant, pour augmenter la
production d'électricité et
réduire le délai de maintenance
opérationnelle.
Nous voulons allonger le plus
possible, et en sécurité surtout,
l'exploitation des 56 réacteurs
aujourd'hui en fonctionnement.
C'est bien ce qu'a dit la Première
ministre lors du débat.
Ensuite, notre proposition serait
de construire des réacteurs.
Je crois qu'il n'y a pas l'once
d'une ambiguïté sur notre
objectif.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Raphaël Schellenberger?
- Raphaël Schellenberger: Je
regrette toujours que quand on
parle du mix énergétique, il est
difficile de discuter avec la
ministre chargée de l'énergie,
pourtant dessaisie de près de 40%
du mix énergétique français dans
l'ensemble de ses compétences.
Pour le reste, il y a quand même
la question du parc nucléaire et
l'âge auquel vous comptez le
fermer.
La Première ministre a fait
entendre que certains de nos
réacteurs pourraient être fermés à
50 ans, alors que nous devons tout
faire pour les faire remonter au
moins 60 ans.
Pour le reste, la réalité, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui, au moment où nous
avons besoin d'électricité, les
éoliennes, tous les jours, ces
derniers temps, alors qu'il fait
froid, elles tournent à hauteur de
2%.
Elles ne produisent quasiment rien
alors que nous avons besoin
d'électricité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Nicole Le
Peih pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Nicole Le Peih: Ma question
s'adresse s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'Europe et des
affaires étrangères.
Hier a été mis en place l'embargo
sur le pétrole russe décidé dans
les pays de l'Union Européenne.
Cette sanction de plafonner le
prix du baril de pétrole russe
doit porter un coup décisif à
l'effort de guerre russe.
Cette décision affectera encore
plus durement les revenus de la
Russie, tout en stabilisant les
prix de l'énergie, ce qui va
profiter à tous les Etats étant
confrontés à des prix du pétrole
élevés.
Ce plafond envoie un signal
nécessaire.
Il est intolérable que les
responsables de ce conflit soient
des profiteurs de guerre.
Alors que la semaine dernière,
notre majorité a voté pour une
résolution en soutien à l'Ukraine
et condamnant l'agression russe,
l'application de cette sanction
témoigne que nous nous tenons,
comme depuis le début, aux côtés
de l'Ukraine dans la souveraineté.
L'application d'une telle mesure,
nous en avons conscience, n'est
pas sans représenter un défi.
Mais l'Union Européenne a déjà
prouvé sa détermination à
renforcer sa dépendance
énergétique vis-à-vis des énergies
fossiles russes, tout en
maintenant son ambition
écologique.
Madame la ministre, comment
évaluez-vous l'impact qu'auront
ces mesures sur le pouvoir de
nuisance de la Russie et quelles
autres sanctions peuvent être
envisagées, en concertation avec
nos alliés, afin d'empêcher la
Russie d'engranger des revenus
nécessaires à son effort de
guerre?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Catherine
Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, madame la
députée, merci de me permettre de
revenir sur cet accord, qui a été
trouvé entre Européens, mais aussi
avec nos partenaires du G7, plus
l'Australie, sur le plafonnement
des prix du pétrole russe.
Ce plafonnement vient compléter
l'arsenal de sanctions déjà
déployées en réaction à
l'agression russe en Ukraine.
C'est une mesure utile, car elle
contribuera à réduire la capacité
de la Russie à mener sa guerre, à
financer sa guerre, en diminuant
les revenus tirés du pétrole.
C'est une mesure qui démontre
aussi la qualité de la
coordination menée au sein du G7
pour sanctionner l'effort de
guerre russe et les profiteurs de
guerre.
Pour la suite, l'Union Européenne
continue de travailler à de
nouvelles mesures, après déjà huit
paquets de sanctions, qui pèsent
sur le régime russe.
Plusieurs options supplémentaires
sont à l'étude, notamment la
restriction d'exportation dans les
domaines technologiques bancaires,
et des services, ainsi que de
nouvelles désignations
individuelles de responsables
politico-militaires et économiques
russes qui soutiennent la guerre.
Nous avons aussi sanctionné les
responsables impliqués dans les
transferts de drones iraniens
utilisés par la Russie en Ukraine
ainsi que les Biélorusses qui
aident la Russie dans sa guerre.
Nous allons continuer à le faire.
Tout ceci sera à l'ordre du jour
du prochain conseil d'affaires
générales à Bruxelles, lundi
prochain.
Rendez-vous lundi 12 décembre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Arnaud Le
Gall.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la souveraineté énergétique.
Le président est allé se plaindre
à monsieur Joe Biden d'un plan qui
instaure la concurrence avec
l'Europe.
En retour, il a eu l'humiliation.
La guerre en Ukraine radicalise la
compétition, comme le montre le
prix exorbitant auquel les
Etats-Unis nous vendent gaz et
pétrole.
Les Etats-Unis sont un grand pays.
Nous avons des défis communs à
relever, mais ils ne considèrent
pas les pays transatlantiques
comme des exemples.
Dans les pays capitalistes, la
concurrence est la règle.
Joe Biden a raison de conditionner
les aides publiques à la création
d'emplois locaux, de relocaliser
les productions pour réduire la
vulnérabilité de son produit et de
consacrer des fonds à la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale et
l'évasion fiscale.
La France est ringardisée, avec
son plan de relance européen qui
n'aura fait que gaver la finance,
son refus de protectionnisme, et
tout ce qui alimente la dette.
Il est urgent de changer et non de
demander à Joe Biden de le faire.
Notre industrie de l'emploi, notre
indépendance énergétique et
sanitaire sont en jeu.
Nous ne devons être dépendants ni
des Etats-Unis, ni de la Russie,
ni de la Chine.
Quand travaillerez-vous à la mise
en place d'un protectionnisme
européen?
N'attendons pas une illusoire
autorisation de l'Allemagne ou de
la Commission européenne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Roland
Lescure, ministre délégué chargé
de l'Industrie.
- Roland Lescure: Merci.
Cette visite du président de la
République à Washington la semaine
dernière est une visite historique
et exceptionnelle.
C'est la deuxième fois qu'un
président en exercice français se
rend en visite d'Etat aux
Etats-Unis.
C'était la première du président
Joe Biden.
Elle a permis d'affirmer une fois
encore une amitié forte, solide,
historique et inscrite dans
l'avenir, entre les Etats-Unis et
la France.
Elle a permis aussi d'avoir un
échange franc, honnête, sur les
enjeux de la compétition
internationale, du soutien de
l'industrie française, européenne
et américaine, par les Etats
respectifs.
Elle a permis d'affirmer que la
compétition juste et loyale entre
deux amis était à l'ordre du jour.
Le président Joe
Biden l'a affirmé.
Il a eu l'occasion de réaliser
combien l'IRA avait pu inquiéter
les Européens.
Vous le savez, le président de la
République et Bruno Le Maire l'ont
affirmé, notre politique de
soutien à l'Union Européenne va se
poursuivre dans une logique de
décarbonation, avec des
conditions.
Les 54 milliards du plan France
relance 2030 sont conditionnés à
des efforts réels.
- Arnaud Le Gall: Vous vivez sur
une autre planète.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
ministre?
- Roland Lescure: Je vous rappelle
que la planète sur laquelle nous
vivons est une planète dans
laquelle la réalité économique
s'impose à tous.
L'amitié historique y est
essentielle.
Le partenariat franco-américain a
encore de beaux jours devant lui.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Pierre
Cordier.
- Pierre Cordier: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, nous
connaissions la France des
lumières.
Avec vous, nous aurons la France
des bougies.
La circulaire que vous avez
adressée
aux préfets, pour qu'ils se
préparent à d'éventuelles
coupures, scandalise nos
concitoyens.
Ces coupures, elles concerneraient
60% des Français, sans faire la
distinction entre des domiciles
vides et des logements de
personnes âgées et dépendantes, ou
de familles avec des enfants en
bas âge.
Les trains, métros ou tramways
pourront être interrompus,
empêchant nos concitoyens d'aller
au travail.
Il y aura des écoles fermées pour
ne pas risquer de se retrouver
sans chauffage, ni lumière, ni
alarme.
Comment notre pays peut-il se
retrouver dans cette situation?
Pourtant, nous pensions avoir tout
vu avec votre gestion calamiteuse
de la crise Covid.
J'ai rencontré des citoyens, hier,
dans mon département des Ardennes.
Les téléalarmes et les téléphones
fixes ne fonctionneront plus.
Les personnes hospitalisées à
domicile seront en danger.
Le préfet ne pourra pas isoler un
logement dans une zone coupée.
Avez-vous pensé aux milliers de
personnes sous assistance
respiratoire, aux porteurs d'un
coeur artificiel qui doivent
recharger leurs batteries, à nos
concitoyens branchés qui ne
peuvent se passer d'électricité?
Nos concitoyens doivent-ils
investir dans des groupes
électrogènes en urgence?
Ce sont 10 ans de gestion
Hollande-Macron qui sont
responsables de cela.
Assumez vos erreurs et trouvez des
solutions.
Ne mettez pas nos concitoyens les
plus fragiles en danger.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, monsieur le
député Cordier, au contraire, les
Français sont rassurés de savoir
que le gouvernement est au travail
pour préparer le passage de
l'hiver dans les meilleures
conditions.
Les Français ont bien vu que, sur
le sujet du gaz, alors même que le
principal fournisseur de l'Europe
était manquant, avec 40% de
fourniture de gaz en Europe, nous
sommes aujourd'hui en capacité de
passer cet hiver sereinement parce
que nos stocks sont remplis, parce
que nous avons anticipé, au niveau
national et européen.
Les Français savent que gouverner,
c'est prévoir.
Prévoir, c'est préparer des plans
dans les situations les plus
extrêmes.
Lorsqu'on prépare un plan blanc ou
un plan rouge, on ne le fait pas
en espérant qu'un avion va
s'écraser.
On le fait pour anticiper le pire
des scénarios.
C'est ce que nous faisons.
Nous sommes à la manoeuvre pour
que ces délestages n'arrivent pas.
Je vous renvoie sur les prévisions
de RTE, qui
nous disent que ces scénarios
extrêmes, nous ne les envisageons
que pour protéger notre pays.
Nous allons continuer à travailler
avec les grandes entreprises, les
administrations, en renforçant nos
interconnexions européennes, pour
éviter les délestages.
Plutôt que d'affoler les Français,
soyez à nos côtés pour faire en
sorte que cet hiver se passe dans
les meilleures conditions.
Ce serait la preuve de votre
responsabilité.
Voter le projet sur les énergies
renouvelables, ce serait également
la preuve de votre responsabilité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Pierre Cubertafon.
- Jean-Pierre Cubertafon: Merci.
Mes chers collègues, ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre
déléguée des collectivités
territoriales et de la ruralité.
L'ambition d'améliorer la qualité
de vie dans les petites communes
et les territoires ruraux a
conduit au déploiement du
programme Petites villes de
demain.
Il a été lancé par le gouvernement
en 2021.
Il regroupe 1640 communes de moins
de 20.000 habitants pour renforcer
les moyens des élus.
Les élus ont encouragé de
nombreuses actions, et des
premières concrétisations sont
visibles.
La mise en place des stratégies de
territoires est en voie
d'achèvement et la priorité doit
aujourd'hui être donnée à la
recherche du plus grand impact
possible sur la qualité de vie des
habitants ainsi que sur la
transition écologique.
Pouvez-vous nous indiquer les axes
de développement du programme
attendu en 2023?
La qualité de vie des habitants de
ces petites villes repose aussi
sur un aspect d'une importance
capitale et grandissante: la
sécurité.
La police et la gendarmerie ont
mis en place des stratégies
locales.
C'est dans cet esprit que les
brigades de gendarmerie et de
police agissent quotidiennement au
service de la sécurité de tous.
En lien étroit avec les services
de l'Etat, le maire doit s'assurer
du bon ordre, de la sécurité, de
la sûreté et de la salubrité
publique, mais aussi de la
prévention de la délinquance.
J'ai une seconde question.
Pouvez-vous nous indiquer les
différentes dispositions et les
mesures choisies afin de permettre
aux maires d'assurer la sécurité
de leurs citoyens?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Dominique
Faure.
- Dominique Faure: Merci.
Je vous remercie de mettre en
lumière un programme important
porté par l'Etat.
Lancé en octobre 2020, il vise à
améliorer la qualité de vie de nos
concitoyens qui vivent dans des
petites villes.
Il a permis de recruter 870 chefs
de projet.
Le but est de réfléchir à des
projets territoriaux et de lancer
de nombreuses actions dont les
résultats sont déjà visibles.
Aujourd'hui, ce programme, c'est
834 millions d'euros engagés, soit
28% des 3 milliards d'euros
prévisionnels.
Le programme en est encore à sa
phase de démarrage.
Je travaille sur des leviers
permettant de renforcer ce
programme et de l'accélérer dans
tous les territoires, y compris
les plus ruraux, pour tirer profit
des 4 ans qui restent.
J'aurai à coeur de réunir
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
afin d'en affirmer les nouvelles
priorités, parmi lesquelles
figurera l'accompagnement à la
transition écologique.
Je sais que les attentes sont
fortes en matière de projets des
collectivités et nous y répondrons
en concertation avec les parties
prenantes.
Je suis convaincue que la qualité
de vie et le développement
territorial des petites villes
passent également par la
prévention et la sécurité.
C'est une question essentielle
pour nos élus locaux et pour nos
compatriotes.
C'est ce que nous promouvons avec
les contrats de sécurité, dans
lesquelles se sont engagées 135
communes qui déclinent au niveau
local une stratégie sur mesure
entre l'Etat et la commune.
Nous avons de l'ambition dans ces
domaines.
C'est une action chère au
gouvernement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Anna Pic.
- Anna Pic: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Education
nationale et de la Jeunesse.
"Je veux vous rassurer, il n'y a
aucun risque de coupure
d'électricité, parce que quand il
y a des besoins, on
s'approvisionne sur le marché
européen."
C'était les mots du président de
la République, qu'il a prononcés
devant la presse quotidienne
régionale.
Ces décisions prises ensuite
viennent contrarier les propos qui
ont été tenus.
Les Français redoutaient quelque
chose qui est devenu réalité.
Il y a quelques jours, vous
confirmiez que les écoles et
établissements scolaires seraient
concernés par ces coupures
d'électricité et seraient amenés à
fermer.
Après l'effet désastreux
de la crise sanitaire, nous
voulons alerter sur la nécessité
de les maintenir ouverts.
Ces fermetures laissent présager
des conséquences néfastes sur la
santé des élèves.
Elles auront également des
conséquences économiques sur les
familles, en termes de garde
d'enfants, et d'autres frais, en
cas de fermeture des cantines.
Il y a aussi la question du
travail des femmes, car ce sont
elles qui resteront à domicile
pour garder les enfants, en
majorité.
Les syndicats n'ont pas été
consultés en amont.
Ils sont mis devant le fait
accompli.
Les inquiétudes sont nombreuses,
tant pour les familles que pour
les collectivités locales, qui
vont devoir mettre en oeuvre ces
mesures.
Que comptez-vous faire pour
apaiser les tensions engendrées
par ces délestages?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci.
Madame la députée Pic, compte tenu
du nombre et de la densité des
écoles et des établissements
scolaires, il est impossible de
les préserver d'une éventuelle
coupure d'électricité, parce que
cela rendrait tout délestage
impossible.
Il a été décidé une règle
nationale: si la coupure est
programmée entre 8h et 10h ou
entre 10h et midi, l'établissement
scolaire concerné sera fermé.
Ce n'est pas pour une raison de
chauffage.
C'est pour une raison de sécurité,
et parce que les systèmes de
sécurité incendie dépendent de
l'électricité.
Pas d'électricité, pas de
sécurité.
Voilà la raison principale.
Je le répète, nous ne sommes pas
dans la même situation qu'à
l'époque du Covid.
Les coupures d'électricité peuvent
ne pas arriver.
C'est une éventualité qu'il faut
envisager.
Sinon, ce serait pour une durée
limitée à 2 heures.
Nous nous tenons prêts, si jamais
une coupure d'électricité devait
se produire dans des zones
spécifiques.
Ca s'appelle le principe de
précaution.
Si jamais une coupure
d'électricité était nécessaire,
trois jours avant, les familles
seraient prévenues que nous
entrons en zone rouge.
La veille, les familles et les
élèves seraient prévenues à 17h.
Nous saurions, en effet, quelles
écoles et quels établissements
scolaires seraient privés
d'électricité.
Cela s'appelle encore le principe
de précaution.
Je vous rappelle que, chaque
année, des dizaines d'écoles et
d'établissements scolaires ferment
de manière inopinée, par exemple
suite à une chute de neige.
C'est ce type d'informations que
nous voulons fournir de manière
raisonnable.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance est terminée.
Je suspends la séance 15 minutes.